40岁之后
你是不是明显的感觉到
眼睛很容易累
血糖血压也开始跟你闹脾气
有两个餐桌上很棒的食物就是
番茄和玉米
这就是我们每天吃的食物啊
没错
不要看它们是平平凡凡的
你知道
番茄搭配哪个食物
血糖更能稳定吗
还有一种玉米
最能保护眼睛
你常常吃呢
视网膜会感谢你哦
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
番茄加它一起吃
稳血糖防老老化
35岁之后啊
你是不是感觉到皮肤
就没有以前那么亮
毛孔也变大了
笑的时候还会
卡细纹
来吃
一组抗老稳血糖的好搭档 特别棒的啊
番茄和洋葱
番茄的茄红素能够清除
你身体里头的自由基
延缓细胞老化
洋葱的槲皮素啊
和硫化物啊
可以抗发炎
能够稳血糖
番茄洋葱搭一起
不只是让你的皮肤年轻
心血管也健康
代谢更好
美丽的太太
番茄洋葱可以煮什么样的料理啊
我会煮
番茄洋葱炒肉片
这好
还有一个是
番茄炒蛋
然后加洋葱
很好吃
嗯
非常好吃
妈妈们
明天来做一道
番茄洋葱料理
你的皮肤得就会
很美丽
血管更年轻
番茄护心抗六种癌
三类人不宜吃
你猜哦
医生看到哪一种蔬菜会变脸吗
苹果吗
不
啊
我告诉你
是番茄
因为义大利人说啊
番茄红了
医生的脸就绿了
这样一颗红通通的番茄
吃了能够让你
顾心脏
让你美白
连癌症都怕它
番茄里面的茄红素是抗氧化之王
吃茄红素有什么好处
女人吃了能够
抗老
美白
男人吃了可以
保护你的摄护腺
强心脏
茄红素更能帮忙
血管做大扫除哦
研究指出
说茄红素能够清除血管里的沉积物
降低坏胆固醇
就是LDL
低密度胆固醇
预防心脏病
番茄营养到连癌症都怕它
研究发现
说常吃番茄的人
可以降低六种癌症的风险
这么厉害啊
是哪六种啊
摄护腺癌
胃癌
肠癌
卵巢癌
子宫颈癌
乳癌
这样很赞耶
是哦
但是要提醒你
有一些人不适合
番茄什么人不能吃
三种人
第一种肾脏病人
肾脏病人或正在洗肾的人啊
为什么要少吃呢
番茄它的钾含量很高
肾不好的人就不能多吃
第二种肠胃不好的人
不要吃太多
因为番茄的苹果酸和柠檬酸
可能导致胃酸过多
胃酸过多
引发胃食道逆流
第三种
正在吃高血压
β受体组织剂的人
建议你先问问医生比较安全啦
三吃法
茄红素翻倍
番茄豆腐抗发炎
美丽的太太
妳在吃什么
番茄沾那个
姜汁
酱油
很好吃耶
你吃吃看
我看得好像黄仁勋
他也是用这个东西来吃是不是
对啊
这是南部人都很喜欢吃
他说他很怀念台湾的姜汁番茄
很好吃耶
我也想吃一吃试试看
对啊你吃吃看
一定很好吃
番茄能够保护血管
姜的姜辣素和姜烯酚
是天然的
抗发炎成份
有效的减轻身体发炎反应
那妳知道番茄生吃好
还是熟吃好妳知道吗
我觉得熟吃好
番茄生吃或者熟吃
都很好
妳生吃番茄
会得到满满的维他命C
有美白提升免疫能力的效果
番茄煮熟以后呢
像是做成番茄炒蛋
可以吃到茄红素
帮助小肠吸收
而且保护心血管
抗发炎抗老化
有三个吃法
让茄红素吸收率翻倍
第一加油吃
第二加热吃
第三挑红一点的番茄来吃
我们先讲加油吃
茄红素是脂溶性的
就是油溶性的
会溶在油里头
所以妈妈们在炒番茄炒蛋
加一点橄榄油的时候
就能大大提升
它的茄红素吸收率
第二个是加热吃
妳把番茄煮熟了以后
会释放出更多的茄红素
茄红素吸收的效果更高
研究显示
在88ºC把番茄
加热两分钟
吸收率6%
加热15分钟的话
吸收率17%
加热半个小时
竟然可以达到35%
哇好厉害
最后第三个
妳买番茄的时候
挑选红一点的番茄
越红的番茄
代表茄红素的含量就越多
煮义大利面的时候
可以煮番茄肉酱
另外一个是可以煮番茄豆腐汤
这两种都很好吃
是
番茄遇上豆腐
茄红素和大豆异黄酮的结合
可以发挥抗氧化作用
而且调节荷尔蒙
并且对抗慢性发炎
提醒妳要注意
番茄跟豆腐在一起吃
不要常常
吃吃 太多并不好
为什么
它可能会造成结石的烦恼
吃一种玉米顾眼睛
防视网膜退化
再来我们要介绍的是
帮妳顾眼睛的玉米
玉米算是蔬菜类吗
不是哦
玉米是全谷杂粮类的淀粉食物
我们最常见的玉米有三种
甜玉米
水果玉米
还有糯玉米
甜玉米呢
眼睛常常酸涩的人
来妳多吃一点甜玉米
甜玉米的叶黄素和玉米黄素
含量很高
有满满的
β胡萝卜素
帮妳保护眼睛
延缓视网膜的退化
第二种是水果玉米
水果玉米
其实就是甜玉米的
一个变种
它有白色的有黄色的
还有黄白双色的
它的甜度更高
口感像是吃水果一样
可以生吃或者是凉拌了来吃
妳知道烤玉米是用哪一种玉米吗
我知道
第三种
第三种是什么
烤玉米
这个是糯玉米
没错
糯玉米有白色的
有带黑紫色的
妳在夜市里头买的就是这一种
也有人用水煮的
糯玉米
咬下去QQ弹弹的有嚼劲
对
膳食纤维也丰富
能够促进肠胃的蠕动
玉米一部位别丢
泡茶消肿降血压
玉米不只是
玉米粒好吃
中医看来它更是一味药
玉米须玉米根叶都是宝
先说玉米粒
它富含不饱和脂肪酸
卵磷脂以及维他命E
能护血管降低胆固醇
你有血脂高的人
平常三餐
就可以吃一些玉米
是满好的
第二个就是玉米
须别把这个宝贝当成废物
把它扔了
好可惜
古人把新鲜的玉米须
烘干磨粉
加一点酒来吃
你知道吗
可以治疗妇女的乳房红肿
乳汁不通
或者怕冷头痛等等的症状
效果就非常的快速
现代人也研究
玉米须茶它的功效是能够
降血压稳血糖
利尿消肿
糖友
高血压的人
你都可以去超商超市
买玉米须茶
当作饮料来喝
是满不错的
第三就是玉米根和叶也能入药
《本草纲目》里头记载
说小便有沙子一样的
淋淋沥沥的那种尿的时候
或者是我们现在讲的叫做
结石的状况
会痛得难以忍受
可以把玉米的根和玉米的叶
煎成汤
频繁的来
饮用水 肿瘦身好朋友
玉米笋比玉米
热量少三倍
想维持苗条身材的女生
跟你说一件事
玉米笋就是你瘦身的好朋友
每100公克的玉米笋
热量只有31大卡
玉米笋的热量只有
玉米的三分之一而已
吃起来脆脆的
嘴巴有满足感
热量又超低
我最近脚有一点胀胀的
那可以吃玉米笋
玉米笋它的钾含量比较高
每100公克玉米笋里头
含有222毫克的钾
有利尿消水肿的效果
你是脚有一点点水肿
就可以适合吃这个东西
玉米笋
玉米笋什么人不能吃
有一种人要少吃
就是尿失禁的人
否则晚上会变成
厕所常客
美丽旳太太
妳知道玉米笋
和玉米有什么不同吗
我知道啦
玉米笋是玉米的
小小的
小小的玉米就对了
就是baby玉米的意思
玉米笋或者叫kids
孕妇吃玉米笋也很好
玉米笋它富含叶酸
可以弥补孕妇的叶酸的需求
适量的吃能够减少胎儿的缺陷
帮助预防神经的缺陷
嗯好吧
好
亲爱的粉丝们
我们已经开启会员频道了
如果你认同我推广中医
照顾自己健康的理念
欢迎每月小额支持
只要花两杯咖啡的钱哦
或成为我们的VIP赞助者
有你同行
我们才能走得更远
真心感谢你